[Music]
we already knew that Microsoft's
upcoming console was going to deliver
six teraflops of GPU performance but
with the companies III press-conference
out of the way we actually learned a
couple new things about the system we're
going to walk you through them right now
so Michael the one of the first things
that we learned about the system is
actually the name it's no longer called
Project Scorpio it's called the Xbox one
X yeah what do you think about the title
it makes sense in terms of keeping it
within the family of Xbox consoles so we
have Xbox 1s which is a standard console
and xbox 1x which is kind of the premium
console so it all makes sense to me yeah
we also learn the price which is four
hundred and ninety nine dollars that's
pretty expensive what do you think about
the place it kind of aligns with my
predictions and a lot of other people's
predictions just because of how much
power this thing is packing into one
console it makes sense that it's $4.99
but I think the interesting part is like
how is that going to compete with the
ps4 Pro which is $100 cheaper it may be
even lower yeah it seems like it's more
it's more powerful though oh yeah
definitely it's way more powerful yeah
and I think you know the internet right
now is saying that it's very expensive
if you want something cheaper there is
the Xbox one house we also got its
release date which is November 7 yeah so
it's coming out this holiday season yeah
they promised to deliver it within the
holiday season and it seems that they
are going to be delivering on that
promise
yeah and then finally we got a look at
what you know the console looks like you
know what did you think yes this for me
I thought this was one of the more
impressive parts was they said this is
the smallest Xbox console to date so not
only is it way more powerful it's also
compacted into the smaller chassis to be
able to do that yes impressive more than
the Xbox 1s which is you know
approximately 40% smaller than Xbox one
so they've really shrunk a hair the size
it's like a smaller black version of the
Xbox 1s yeah and it looks sleek if I fit
it anywhere in your home entertainment
system so you know that was one of the
cooler parts with the Microsoft
conference you know while Microsoft is
pitching the console is a 4k capable
system the company also said that it's
going to be making improvements to 1080p
gaming as well you're going to get
faster load times and a strop ik
filtering and super sampling do you mind
walking through you know users do what
those some of those things are oh yeah
super sampling is if you're in a 1080p
display it'll essentially be the
will rendering like Ohio continued again
and be condensed so the image quality is
much more fine
so people do don't have 4k displays will
still reap some benefits you know we saw
the games running in 4k but the whole
press conference and I never really saw
any massive frame drops out I don't
think everything was running at a steady
60 frames per second yeah but rendering
4k is a feat within itself it's very
good man yeah and nothing looked frame
me nothing looked like choppy overall
with all the games they shop which
showed off from like triple-a titles
indie titles like look great overall I'm
impressed think this is what Microsoft
needed to do looks all good to me
gotcha yeah it seems like it's a console
that you can get if you have 1080p
screen now and then you can get some
benefits that way and then later if you
wanted to you can help with to a 4k TV
and like you know continue to get better
benefits right right and then the last
thing is you know the console you know
by itself is is is fine but what about
the games you know what you think about
the games they showed me a partisan
screed origins I think was called metro
was exodus which I thought looked
amazing yep
what'd you think about the you know the
lineup of games and how they looked okay
well in terms of the lineup
I was super hyped up for to see Metro
Exodus to see it running it looked
really smooth - because Metro has a long
history of being one of the more
graphically demanding games with 2033
and last light yeah now this one it's
like it's it seems like it's going to be
in that same line of impressively
yeah yeah yeah or just ring in 4k it's
yeah on account unbelievable yeah on a
constable rested in for at 4k look
really smooth and see you know other
games like shadow of war Assassin's
Creed you know they look great too
they're also rendering 4k only thing was
some of the lighting maybe some of the
textures weren't on par with what we
would see if we cranked a PC version all
the way up to ultra which is fine I mean
I'm not gonna expect a console to run 4k
and like super fine textures all at the
same time but they ran smooth which is I
think is the most important part yeah
look it looked playable if you liked
this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to us on YouTube thank you for
watching
you
you